this is less of a talk than it is an
apology
I write last week in AWS and I host the
screaming in the cloud podcast and I
inadvertently have spent the last three
years misleading you all I've been a
staunch advocate for cloud I now know
that this was wrong and I wish to
apologize unreservedly it doesn't matter
which vendor Google Amazon Microsoft
Oracle it's all the same it is expensive
and you deal with lock-in it's not
acceptable so instead I'm going to
handle it differently what you may not
be aware of is I have a side project
called Twitter for pets it's the leading
social network for pets it's like
regular Twitter only 80 times less
racist they're good dogs and we are not
going to do it on cloud we're going to
build our own data center we hop in the
Twitter for pets corporate jet with the
pets and we fly to a different city we
don't put our data center in the same
city because of dr concerns and real
estate in San Francisco's expensive
we're based there because that's where
the good developers live our first data
center we tour as a super-nice security
guard he lets us in and doesn't need to
see our ID that's an instant fail
because we have auditors we manage both
medical and financial data for the pets
it's a hard fail the second data center
we look at her one-line diagram it's an
art it's an electrical cord a graph of
everything in the system they show four
transformers we walk through two pads
two transformers it's aspirational it's
a joke it's a one-liner diagram we visit
the third data center things seem mostly
fine we shake hands we sign a three-year
contract everything gets done we can
start moving in and only for short
months we start buying servers from Dell
it turns out that when we wind up
placing orders we have to schedule it
carefully if it goes too soon we pay
extra storage charges if they don't know
it's coming they wind up leaving them
out in the rain because of this because
Dell screws it up we get both they leave
it in the rain and charge us for it
we smile we saw life goes on we unpacked
some boxes there's no fiber we don't
need a g-pack cisco screwed it up they
sent us the fiber version and
that of the copper version we open a
support case it only takes four short
hours we then wind up building out our
data center cage we check it end-to-end
it contains no children this is
apparently out calm a hard thing to do
this doesn't render us ineligible for
some government contracts but that's
okay unlike many tech companies we will
not name Twitter for pets has standards
it turns out we were wrong there is in
fact fiber there okay we're gonna need
that gee BIC that's a bit of a problem
fortunately that private case is still
pending we can swap it out it's annoying
life goes on these are rack nuts this is
why everyone bleeds while building data
centers they tear your hands to hell
your eyes do not deceive you there are
four different sizes no they are not
compatible yes we buy four different
kinds because whatever we get we know
we're going to be wrong we rack a bunch
of servers eleven are perfect the
twelfth does not we begin by ignoring
because we're adults and professionals
it only takes us four short hours to
figure out the problem the problem is it
turns out as a failed cable this happens
from time to time we always have a cable
tester for that exact reason we also
bring in the world's best firewall we
cut the cable when we throw it away why
do we cut the cable we're putting into
the trash terrific question I'd like to
introduce you to someone
his name is Dewey Dewey has a job that
job is called remote hands he works for
the data center and charges seventy five
bucks an hour to do simple tasks for 125
there's a smart hands option which
really says insulting things about Dewey
but he's a trooper he lets it slide two
o'clock in the morning in the hotel we
get a phone call
that's right Nagios it's the original
call of duty we rush back to the data
center what happened well it's pretty
obvious once we get there
we go back and take a look at the
networking side of things to remember
that fiber
yeah it's loose for a reason it turns
out that one of the remote hands people
decided to tighten it for us so it
wouldn't get caught on anything
tighten fiber it breaks it breaks it
doesn't pass light TCP now terminates on
the floor it's a problem we believe
strongly in the icon in the culture of a
blameless post mortem we conduct a root
cause analysis and blamelessly determine
the
root causes Dewey we talk about hiring
potentially smarter hands budget makes
that a bit of a non-starter
we finally get back on the plane and fly
back to begin work on our application
and that plane is the only part of that
story did that did not happen at a data
center build-out for one company this is
not worst case this is typical case but
we own our own destiny we are able to
build out our own stuff without lock-in
and now we can begin writing our code as
soon as we finish installing kubernetes
which is a short thing to do when you
don't get what you want you get
character my name is Cory Quinn I'm a
character
[Applause]